oh
what what
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the returned bloody
nights we're on Wednesday which means
that I'm probably gonna die again
because I didn't even realize that no no
no I didn't even realize that the
flashlight was a thing were those guys
always there okay does that mean the
flashlight is always there
interesting
fascinating
man it's kind of the disadvantage of
having a larger monitor now
I feel like I just have so much more
real estate to die in
uh all right so I think I died to an
endoskeleton last time and I'm not 100
sure where the end is probably came from
there
well what I don't know is was it on the
monitor
was it here looking at me lurking at me
how did it get in where did it come from
I don't know what was with that minigame
hate that
oh hi hello
good to see you
don't kill me
please don't kill me do I need to check
these for that thing how am I gonna oh
thrown back in the deep end of Five
Nights at Freddy's once more okay so
you're there you're there
I don't know where any of you's is
okay I don't know
it's back to frantic mode
the
good old Five Nights at Freddy's
experience that everyone knows and loves
panicking and screaming
oh it's screaming
there's no ah there's no way I don't
hello okay so you're not here yet you
definitely don't have an end what is
that I don't know
is he gonna be there
I don't know
oh God by me
oh
I'm dead I'm a dead man I can feel it oh
I'm dead
I'm a dead man
well all right then well that's fun
how long are you gonna be there
you still there
how do I know when you're not there
oh God
oh oh
okay I'm assuming you're not there good
bear not be
all right
okay
starting to get a feel for it again the
old instincts are coming back are you oh
oh what are you what are you
wait a minute oh why
who's doing that
who's doing that I see you down there
but I don't know what's going on here
I don't know if that's Bonnie or what
have you
oh
this one's tricky
this one's a little tricky just because
I don't know what anything does yet
you're not there
and I'm not gonna get ahead of myself
start slamming doors and panicking I'm
above that
I'm not really above that
oh oh well that's a problem
you know what I'm just gonna
preemptively
I know it's oh God
I don't know where you're supposed to be
yeah that's fine okay oh
that's probably fine I don't know
there's something in there Freddy's on
the left and there's some
um
and you're something I don't know what
you are though
I don't know
but I don't like it what was that
whoa oh that's a problem
[Music]
all right uh so you're still
Bonnie is nowhere
that's the problem
you done yet God you weren't even there
yet
okay fine
we're good apparently
apparently very good
I don't know
I don't know man this is stressful
how are you doing what is that sound
I hear something to my left oh
what
I don't know what I'm hearing in my left
but I was here hey
laughs
for luck I don't know what that was
about
ah it's uncomfortable what are you doing
in there
oh God
oh and my door's open
closed
what is that
what oh wait I saw you oh you were hard
to see
oh
okay so you're coming over there so
I don't know what's going on here
what
[Music]
what is that
I'm gonna die because my generator
[Music]
oh frick
what is Hobby are you there
bye
[Music]
what are you
what are you oh God I'm doomed
what
is that
[Music]
peek-a-boo
okay thank you
am I good
what
what in the freaking what it was that
oh my God oh my God what is that about
someone was crying over here
[Music]
I haven't
I haven't a clue
I have an a clue I haven't got a clue
right yeah okay
[Applause]
oh my God was that death did I somehow
narrowly avoid death there
oh my God
what is this game
what are you trying to do to me
what was that about
where did that come from ah yeah let me
do my analyzes here is something wrong
with your eyes
hmm
uh-huh
yep nothing weird here
nothing weird here
everything's a-okay
oh
yeah
yeah just fine you Stay classy
all right let's go into Thursday more
lore please
hello William
how are things going with the new
restaurant busy but we're on track for a
successful opening tomorrow
glad to hear it
and have you taken all the necessary
safety measures yeah of course I don't
need anyone telling me how to run my
business
and those employees who think otherwise
can find work elsewhere
I understood
and what about your family
how's everyone doing
Elizabeth has been with me at work for
the past few days
but as for Michael and Evan
they've been influenced by their
mother's lies
Michael is too busy being a typical
rebellious teenager Devin is just a
young child who doesn't understand the
situation
frankly
I'd rather keep my distance from them
for the time being they're at home at
the moment
I see
have you tried to have a conversation
with your wife about this
it's not worth the effort
he's always been self-centered doesn't
care about the family's well-being she's
even had the audacity to call me a
hypocrite
but let's not focus on that right now
let's talk about the restaurant how's
the safety yeah sure but don't forget
about your family
they're important too
I don't need you to remind me of that
I know it's important
now if there's nothing else I have work
to do
actually I just wanted to say that I
worry about you
I hope the restaurant success will make
you happy
thank you for your concern I appreciate
it but I have no time for your pity
I'll talk to you soon
man these calls with Andrew Henry is
quite nosy Henry doesn't know how to
mind his own business and stop talking
about safety so much how's the family
that was a depressing situation with
your family is that uh is that a
collection of all the animatronics that
I'm going to be dealing with
in this mess
congratulations on making it tonight
four I must say I'm impressed with your
work so far you're doing a fine job and
I'm proud of you ah my neck
feels like it's been bitten half and
twisted like a pretzel I slept like a
rock last night but I woke up feeling
like I got hit by a truck I had this
weird dream where I was half robot half
human and let me tell you it wasn't
pretty my legs were replaced with rusty
old scrap metal and I was clunking
around like some kind of junkyard
Frankenstein
would you imagine me like that talk
about a nightmare
anyway enough about my weird dreams now
I must confess I forgot to mention
something earlier we have some new robot
prototypes in the building that we just
introduced yesterday
mentioning this earlier but you handle
the situation like a pro and no damage
was done kudos to you now those robots
are brand spanking new they haven't even
had their first oil change yet they
require some more work before they're
ready for prime time and to be honest
they're giving me the heebie-jeebies
especially that new bunny one
that Bunny's new hide and seek function
is going to be a hit with the kids just
make sure it doesn't start seeking you
out too
I'm not confident you'll handle it you
seem like a tough cookie
oh by the way I'm glad you participated
in this morning's voice recording
session for the tapes you sounded
fantastic what maybe I'll need you again
for any updates what now
moment of being interrupted what's up
Karen there's this document that just
arrived what it's well
it's better for you to look at it
a noticed document about the closure of
all our restaurants due to
investigations regarding one of the
founders being convicted of a crime
including Frederick's family that's
outrageous I
all right all right I understand
oh God oh God
thanks for bringing the note Karen
Karen Karen Karen he's trying to bring
down
the car sure you we have
to fear Fazbear entertainment is as
clean as a whistle on that founder is as
innocent as a newborn baby trust me on
this one kid
I apologize for that Interruption it is
unpleasant news
won't mess with your work schedule oh
you're about to go
just fine
oh yeah one more thing if you if you
keep hearing strange noises or distorted
voices it's probably just our new fret
bear roaming around you know how these
things go always causing trouble we're
working on fixing its music box which is
also supposed to make them talk but in
the meantime just remember to keep that
door shut if it gets too close to your
office
and I'll get you on the flip side
okay
what happened
I'm good
oh I'm not good
oh I hate this I oh that's a problem
isn't it
well it's probably a problem Who would
know
not me
wouldn't know anything about these
things
no not that not that not any of this go
away
here huh
hi
some horrible
horrible walking speaking spell going on
here and then robots at every turn
you're creeping around the corner there
am I clear
oh
all right I think I'm clear well you're
back good
please don't
what was that
I have no idea this is horrible in so
many ways
it's gonna do it I'm just gonna do it
you you are just the worst
I hate
how
this patently unfair
oh
what
see the thing is I didn't get to read
what that was what did you want me to
know about that playing hide and seek
and doing what now to who how is
anybody's about to do that all right so
hide and seek it was something about
I don't know Finding on the cameras and
then
yeah I don't know something
am I supposed to find them on the camera
is that what it's supposed to be
because I hope not
because that would be every kind of
awful yeah I don't know if that's just a
mission to keep you engaged on the
cameras wow you guys are just Trucking
down here
you guys are just
storming your way down
oh yeah
you guys are on the way
yeah that's right what
I don't care
don't like it
[Music]
easy
why does that keep happening I don't
know which door is the one where these
steps are coming from
but I have this crazy feeling
like
it would be my end
what
what you are
there we go
yeah
oh yeah
look look out I'm sorry look out
whoa you're here
I am
here
oh I see you oh I see you you're hiding
and you're seeking I know you're there
but I'm in trouble
this damn door
[Music]
I don't know what to do about that
seems like a problem what do I do about
you I'm just gonna just gonna just gonna
call me a
oh well that's a problem
[Music]
sure
foreign
oh that was luck that was pure luck that
I time that up wow oh God oh God
I'm gonna trust am I good
oh God
yeah I I don't know man
dude I don't know anything I don't know
nothing about nothing
death comes for us all well that's not
good
[Music]
hello
don't don't
I hate it
so I see two
silhouette of a robe nope
crop cake oh handy
you there
oh God
[Music]
what's going on over there
oh what what was that
what
I don't know am I good
I don't know
Frick if I know
Rick if I know man
what did I just see
[Music]
oh this is a problem
oh God
[Music]
really fine
good
this is going so good
I'm so lucky
man I am just the luckiest man alive
hate hate hate hate hate
hate God I hate this
[Music]
nope not gonna do that
oh yeah this is a problem
I'm a dead man
I hate it
stop saying look out
oh that's bad
I'm fine
God damn it
stop that
oh man I feel like I haven't moved this
fast since I was playing 20 modes
God
oh frick that
oh
man it was ready for me whatever was on
the right over there was ready for me
all right
oh
[Music]
what
well I don't know if you were able to
keep up with any of that oh this guy hey
Mr Mister hey look out over here
look out Mister hey
over here
hi
oh I'm getting a reading is that
annoying is that annoying to you oh I'm
sorry am I freaking you out oh am I
causing a star oh
whatever oh
it's the scariest of all
a normal human huh well that was fun and
terrifying that was awful in almost
every way that was awful but I loved it
this is one of the scariest uh fan games
I've ever played just in that it just
never stops that's it for this episode
let me know if you want me to finish
this out there's both Friday there's
Saturday there's custom modes game modes
there's a lot to like here I think this
is really really good so thank you
everybody so much for watching more FNAF
in the link in the description below
more FNAF everywhere on my channel
thanks again and as always I will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]